Dude got a D in algebra II. Does it matter?
It doesn't matter at all what you get in algebra,
unless you're going to be an algebra trician dude.
One time, one time I was, I was doing algebra in my, in my high school class.
And, and I was like, I'm a mom was like,
you really got to work harder on algebra. It's hard.
I just never made any sense.
I had a teacher named Mrs. Weaver and I was getting a D and we have to make it.
We have to make it. I have, I had to do better and I was trying to do better,
trying to do better.
And then all of a sudden they introduced imaginary numbers and I straight up
said in my head, go yourself, dude. Imaginary numbers. No,
all the imaginary. You got eight apples in the Nate apples,
walk in the door and guess what? There's no apples though.
Did you know that you're making it all up?
These are all problems you're making up. Okay.
You want to know the most Asian thing you can do if you're an American Asian,
is this playing with your pen and doing tricks with your pen like that?
Everyone in lock-in yada,
all the American Asians would do this and they'd catch it.
And I learned how to do that in algebra and I can still do it.
And I'm not even 40. I know, but when I get older, dude, I'm going to,
always be and twirling it like this. Oh, wow. Such a anyway, dude.
Uh, imaginary numbers, bro. No, no, I wish that's the thing.
I wish I was me now back then. And I know people like to think, like,
I know what people like, everyone knows that I wish I knew back then.
What I know now, dude, I don't even care about knowing the.
I wish I was more outspoken because I was that dude back then too,
I had all the opinions, but it just, didn't really revel in it.
I needed to,
I need to be an algebra now as a 17 year old and I need Mrs.
Weaver to be saying, Oh,
so these are we're introducing imaginary numbers. And then I go like this. No,
they're all imaginary.
You making up all these problems by none of this should exist,
dude. And if you listen to this and you're 17, first of all,
turn it off because I'm a bad cause. Bad influence.
But also now algebra sucks, dude.
And I'm almost 40. And I'm telling you that now, you know how they're like,
well, when you get older, you know, you don't do it.
And I'm not a bad influence, dude. this man.
I'm telling you right now you high school kids get out of that algebra class due
to high school is you got to do it because they got to figure out how
to make it. So kids don't stab each other and do heroin.
You understand? That's what high school is.
So all the kids just kind of chill out, hang out,
learn how to be with each other. That's why I call it.
College is too early. Everyone should go to college. When they're 26, 27, 28.
That's when, cause that's the thing it's everyone's you're not done develop.
I'll tell you what I was immature kid
until I was 33 or 34.
I was a late bloomer for real.
I went through puberty a little bit late and I was not an adult until I was 34
35. I did immature with selfish as. That's the thing,
dude, 18. You want me to go to college at 18? That's why?
When everyone goes to 18, it goes to college at 18.
They go absolutely bonkers man.
All of a sudden the dorky kid is the cool kid ever. You know that is,
was like, Hey, you,
you come back for the spring for the summer break or spring break.
And they're like, Hey, we're all going to Robert's house. Robert. Robert who?
Robert. Dolman what? Yeah,
the kid was a dork bro. He runs Pepperdine. What
are you kidding me? Are you kidding? Are you kidding me bro?
I went to visit him in Mizzou. Oh,
that guy runs it. Dude. He's practically Chris Brown at Mizzou.
What?
He wear the trench coat bro. He doesn't wear that anymore. He's got green hair.
That's not cool. Where do you see him bro? It's pretty popping.
And then he shows up with like some chick named Haley and you're like,
Oh she's from Saint Francis. She's from the other school. God, this guy's in.
And everybody wants to be friends with Rob that's because
we all go to college too or too early.
Rob didn't even figure out who the he was till he went to Mizzou.
And now it's on in pop it in. And by the time that yeah, God people change.
I hated that. I was who I was in high school bro.
And now I am who I am and that not change. And dude,
It's funny, dude. How that happens though?
We all go. We go away. And then we become who we become. That's dude, I,
Oh man. I that bothered me man. When I was a kid,
like people would go study abroad and they'd come back and and they'd be like,
yeah, girls will be like lost my virginity. And dudes would be like,
took a backpack, walked around a little bit, read a book.
Now I know how [inaudible] check in with me.
We're.
All lost. We're all lost, man.
We go to college too early. That's why now there's people with like, uh,
you know, uh, you see that guy walking a bird flying that guy.
Cause he went to college too early. You saw that guy thing on Twitter.
He was running down the street with two parrots on a leash and the
parents were flying and he was running with those parents.
That guy should get all the
and I'm not joking girls.
That guy deserves all of it for real.
Don't even know what he looks like, but he's gangster.
If I were like, if I was a guy, I gotta walk birds, man.
I gotta walk birds. Do you know how? I didn't know.
You could walk birds. You know what I'm talking about? Right?
You guys have seen this. The birds are flying the guys running.
Kay. I didn't know you could walk birds, bro.
I never even thought of that. This guy is living in 2050.
The birds are level two birds. Are they?
How come we don't talk about how cool birds are man.
But unless you're Brian Callan, we got to all start get, we got us.
That's what that's the thing about high school is that the
classes are all the classes because they need to figure out
the basic,
they need to all conform to all of the certain types of people.
I didn't like that because I'm not doing the that everyone
does. Cause I, you know, Y don't wanna don't wan. Okay.
So that's why if I was you remember electives and, you'd be like,
well I'd like to get into home-ec. I'd like to, even those were.
I'm talking about dude, when I was w w as soon as you get an eighth grade,
I should have been able to sign up for bird walking class
And S and, and there should have been a standup comedy class or whatever the.
And not even a class, it's a stupid class to have, but like,
some kids want to be a magician. I want to be a magician. So now what? Oh,
well there's no magician class. Okay.
So at least let's just have the teachers guide the people and try to learn some
magic to teach to the kids.
That's why I like David Blaine. He doesn't even really do. I mean,
he does magic, but also he'll be like,
I'll just stand in a spot for seven weeks. And you're like, Oh, well,
that's not magic. And he's like, but I'm testing my body. And you're like, okay.
I agree. It tests in your body.
I can just break out of these handcuffs. Really? Yeah. Wow.
That's amazing. It takes eight weeks. Oh,
so you just keep on trying to break them and then finally there's wear and tear
and then open. Yeah. Okay. Is it magic?
I'm testing my body. Okay. But it can do card tricks to my babies.
So som do our car tricks to Al Pachino. And that's a real story.
I live in a fantasy.
I saw David Blaine do a card trick to Al
Pachino and guy Fieri was there and Sylvester,
Stallone was filming it. I live.
In a fantasy.
And then, and then, and then,
and then did David Blaine say to Al Pachino pick a suit and then did
opportunities say, well, I was an Armani the other day. Ah,
I live in a fantasy I'll Pitino turned to me and he said,
remember that card. I live in a fantasy, Albert, you know,
turned over to me and said, there's my card. Remember it? And then I said,
well, I will, I will actually never forget any of this in my life.
Okay. Was the seven of diamonds. Um,
so, so anyway, uh, that's crazy. So
I, you know, the high school should be more specific. That's why it's specific.
You got to get specific high schools, man.
There should be clumps of high schools that are like,
for certain things like the entertainment high schools that they have some time
to have, like some of them in Texas or some dance, high schools,
they got those weird ones. I used to think those were weird,
but they're probably right. [inaudible]
if you know, you love animals and you want to go to a sanctuary high school,
like an animal sanctuary high school and just chill with zebras and
gophers loved the dude. That would,
I hated that when I was in,
when I was in elementary school and the guy would come with all the animals,
everyone loved it. Well it's animal day. We get to come out.
The guy comes with animals and it'd be like, got class. This is a gopher.
And Steven [inaudible] would be like, Oh,
and there'd be some kid with a closed throat because a gopher came out.
We're like, Oh, sorry. Matthew's allergic.
He's got to go home now in the eighties, nobody gave a.
Now come bring animals. I wonder if they still do that, they probably don't.
They used to bring snakes out, dude. Hey, they could kill us.
Like, why not just bring a wild boar? Oh yeah. It's snake up. There's this up.
This next wallet, Tommy. We didn't like him anyway,
dude. Why not just bring a wild boy, bring a high. They should just bring a,
imagine them bringing just a starving hyena. Hey, class, gather around.
It's just like, this is a hyena. Oh, Whoa. It's thrashing. Oh, Whoa,
Whoa. Okay. It has Danny Vic's arm. Whoa.
It's thrashing Danny Vic's arm hair. You're not swallow mine.
I swallow my arm. Um, anyway.